هذه الصور والمشاهد التي وصلتنا ننقلها
لكم لعمليات نزوح من الخرطوم مع استمرار
الاشتباكات اذا عدد كبير من الباصات
الواحد تلو الاخر الان هي باتجاه ولايات
اخرى الخرطوم العاصمه السودانيه اصبح
الوضع فيها خطر للغايه كما يقول المواطنون
السودانيون لم تعد منطقه امنه هناك في
السودان في الخرطوم بالتحديد العاصمه
السودانيه مطرا الناس للزحف نحو الولايات
الاخرى والابتعاد عن العاصمه العاصمه
السودانيه اليوم بلا ماء بلا كهرباء بلا
وقود هذا كله يضاف الى الازمه الاقتصاديه
التي كانت اصلا موجوده خصوصا بعد ثوره عام
2019 بعد الاطاحه بنظام البشير ومن بعدها
توالت الازمات وتعقدت الامور لحين الوصول
كان الى بقعه امل في الضوء وخصوصا فيما
يتعلق بتوقيع الاتفاق الاطاري ومن حدث ما
حدث واندلعت الاشتباكات بين الطرفين
العسكريين في السودان ولكن دائما المواطن
هو من يدفع الثمن المواطن اليوم السوداني
يعيش حاله من الخوف وحاله من الذعر هذه
السيارات وهذه الباصات خير دليل على ما
يحصل في السودان اليوم الناس تذهب بالمئات
وبالعشرات يعني تشاد تقول بان وصلها عشرين
الف سوداني منذ ان بدات الاحتجاجات اليوم
هذه الصور نوضح لكم لعمليات النزوح الى
ولايات اقل خطرا والى مدن اقل خطرا ولا
توجد فيها هذه الاشتباكات وحجم الماساه
اليوم طبعا هذا الصراع ياخذ ابعادا عده من
انه صراع بدا بين طرفين عسكريين متحاربين
الى
سيناريوهات متوقع ان تكون اكثر تصعيدا
تذهب بها البلاد الى حرب اهليه واندلاع
مظاهرات من قبل الشارع وطبعا كلا يتمنى كل
هذه السيناريوهات لكنها باتت متوقعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات